all right what's going on guys this is
rob and uh because i'm on vacation this
week uh we're picking up with part two
of remastering adam the legend of blue
marvel because as most anybody who has
been around this channel long enough
knows i absolutely love this story and
and again you know like we said in the
last video it's really because of the
fact there's just a lot of history here
one of the things to know and and kind
of picking up for those of you guys who
are joining us in this this second video
again i highly suggest you go back and
watch the first video but in the face of
of going against anti-man conor sims
it's one a level of power that the
mighty avengers are not used to right i
mean this guy even took the century for
a ride which is no small feat but also
it's a villain they know nothing about
and that's one of the things to
understand here is that most of the
villains the superheroes face off
against they're aware of even if they've
somehow returned with a higher level of
power than they had before for example
someone like michael korvac or something
like that they at least know enough
about him that they know how to approach
the situation anti-man is an anomaly
they know nothing about this guy and so
that's why the first thing that happens
is you have reed and you have uh tony
stark and you have uh hank pym who
basically meet up now the other reason
why this happens and again we talked
about this in the last video but it
doesn't hurt to reiterate here is that
these are the three minds that are
behind the initiative remember this
takes place almost immediately after the
events of civil war so you still have
the superhero initiative like the 50
state initiative that kind of a thing
and it was hank and it was read and it
was pim that were instrumental in
organizing and setting everything up and
are really kind of the masterminds
behind the show to a degree but one of
the things that happens and one of the
things they talk about here is that in
the fight between them anti-man
mentioned blue marvel and that's when
hank pym chimes in and says wasn't there
a hero from the early 60s that was named
that guy that had that name now this is
one of the distinct things that i want
to bring up here technically speaking in
terms of marvel publishing right if we
look at when marvel published comics
black panther was the first black
superhero in marvel comics really the
first black superhero with their own
solo series you could really look at
falcon and say he was the first one but
in terms of what's going on insofar as
this being a retcon a retroactive
continuity what kevin grievious is doing
here is saying before falcon ever became
or before uh sam wilson ever became
falcon before t'challa ever showed up in
the united states there was blue marvel
so blue marvel is in fact the first
black superhero to exist on earth within
the marvel universe continuity so that's
an important distinction to explain
there but it's also the way that he's
able to get away with someone like hank
pym saying like wasn't there a superhero
in the 1960s who had that name but the
reality here is it's one of these things
where he's just kind of a lost superhero
to a degree he was before their time
they didn't really seem to focus on him
all that much and so in a lot of ways
kevin grievous is kind of asking us to
suspend disbelief here because the
reality is that having a superhero who
saves the world from an asteroid the
size of kansas that's not something that
you just forget right like remember that
guy that saved the earth from total
obliteration by like a giant meteor what
was that guy's name i mean obviously
they would remember who this guy is so
there's a little bit of suspension of
disbelief that goes on here but at the
end of the day what they also come to
realize is that uh based on reed
richards and him analyzing the entirety
of the fight the situation things like
that that this guy anti-man is basically
based on anti-matter technology right
like literally anti-matter energy
essentially what we're saying is that
this guy is potentially powered by an
infinite source of energy he uses it as
fuel so imagine how galactus uses the
power cosmic an infinite source of
energy that's what anti-man is except he
uses antimatter energy now he's kind of
an unfinished product right he's kind of
one of these things where he's not the
perfected version of this and in fact
we'll get more into that when we talk
about the origin of adam bashir and so
on and so what happens here is one thing
to remember in the aftermath of civil
war tony stark became director of shield
and so the first thing he does is he
says okay let's accent shield technology
let's access their database and find out
who this guy is the problem is that all
information pertaining to adam brashear
is classified above top secret not even
tony stark can access it even as
director of shield and remember as
director of shield this guy's got
basically access to the world's
information that's out there right so
the nsa the kgb everything every
intelligence agency that exists in the
world shield has access to their
databases and he still can't find this
guy right he's like literally
cross-reference everything the name adam
brashear with every current piece of
information that exists out there all
known files and references with shield
the fantastic four the x-men the
avengers the whole nine yards and its
negative results and he says
cross-reference with nsa cia fbi through
interpol link international intelligence
organizations the mi6 write the dgse
most sad kgb like everything and like
it's scan scan scan and there's just a
single kgb file that's linked to the nsa
but he can't get to it right so what one
little crumb he found in relation to
this guy doesn't exist and the reality
is that it's all locked away due to
executive order bm349 that's a
presidential decree and so what this
means is the president of the united
states at the time locked away any and
all information pertaining to blue
marvel and no one can access it and so
that's when he's kind of like what are
the blue marvel protocols and that's
when he's basically given access to this
and he's like what in the hell is going
on and so as he starts reading through
these to a degree he gets a bit of
information we're not given the full
totality of the information he gets and
even the information that tony stark
gets is not in his full totality so the
only thing he does is the only thing he
really can do he goes and visits dumb
dumb dugan now the reason why he does
this is one because nick fury's always
gone he can never find the guy and two
because dum-dum dugen served during
shield at that point in time he was
basically was like boots on the ground
when everything with blue marvel was
happening and so that's when he's like i
need you to tell me everything you know
about the blue marvel protocols and the
response of dumb dumb dugan is leave it
alone you do not want to go down this
rabbit hole tony stark like you do not
want to go down this whole path this is
going to lead you to a place that you
don't want to be and there's a reason
why blue marvel and everything regarded
to it was swept under the rug right i
mean literally it's one of these things
where stark's like you were part of this
cover-up right really like kind of
interrogates him and then in the end
duke's response is like talk what you
know shellhead i had nothing to do with
it and neither did fury if that's what
you were thinking right fury had no real
hand in the way that that blue marvel
was blackballed and the way that we saw
it done in the first issue and he says
neither of us agreed with that but in
the end you need to leave this alone
right you need to walk away from this
this is not something that you need to
have any involvement in and so what he
does here is he sends him in the
direction of a guy by the name of croots
now he doesn't dump all this information
here he simply says that's the guy that
can give you the kind of details that
you're looking for or at least he can
give you the the gritty details that i
simply just can't give you because one
of the things to remember is that while
dum dum dugen was there his information
is really kind of limited to what nick
fury passed on to him and like word of
mouth which for the most part was
relatively accurate but there's a
difference between being the guy who's
on the outside looking in and being the
guy who was on the inside and that's
what crews was he was there at the
ground level when it was all happening
so what happens is tony stark travels to
falls church virginia and he meets up
with crews now here's one of the things
that i want to specify in this kevin
grievous does not really shy away from
the racial issues that plagued the
united states in the 1960s and in fact
cruz is presented to us as essentially a
holdover from that era right from that
time period a reminder of how people
functioned at that point in time and so
when tony stark starts asking him
questions like do you know what's going
on with blue marvel and all that kind of
stuff that what really happens here is
he says yep you know he's like i'm well
aware of all of this stuff right like
there was literally this guy right when
anti-man first showed up the blue marvel
took him down hard and so the response
to stark is so the blue marvel saved
lives and you got rid of him anyway and
in the end kroot's response well it was
just a different it was a different time
right it was a different time period and
he says like i'm not proud of what i've
done stark like i know how it was that i
used to think and i know the things that
i've said about colors and in response
start correction and says african
americans and the response of crews is
whatever now while croots is not really
being being depicted here as the racist
he was in the 1960s the reality is he
hasn't necessarily moved on he still
lives to a degree in the way things were
before and that's why he says things
like he refers to adam beshear as boy
right he's like that brashear boy was
dangerous and where stark's like why are
you referring to him as a boy the
response of cruz is like dude are we are
we really going to go through this time
and time again and the reason why this
is a significant moment here is because
what it's showing is generational
differences right recruits this is just
common nomenclature it's common phrase
it's no different than you and i saying
man that's cool right whereas to tony
stark it's like that's old school man
it's an old archaic way of thinking and
it is by all standards of measurement
racist right but in the end tony stark
wants information more than he wants to
correct crits's way of thinking besides
cruz is already on his deathbed the
guy's not long for this world anyway so
croots really starts to come clean with
the stuff that he knows and he says
brashears scared the living crap out of
everybody it was 1962 we were scared of
everything back then aliens russians
right the red [ __ ] negro rights
right that kind of a thing and he said
and in the end the response of stark is
like the world was changing and you
could have done the same and that's
where crew responds and saying what the
hell do you think would have happened to
this country to the world if they knew
that there was a colored man running
around who could lay waste to a
continent now this is a point he makes
not necessarily as a disparaging mark to
adam bashir but in saying at that point
in time in the united states that he
makes a point saying it was a country of
like legal segregation that
institutionalized hate characterized a
lot of people what adam beshear
represented was not necessarily the idea
that a black man could rise to
prominence what he represented was
progress and it was the kind of progress
that a lot of people at that point in
time simply didn't want to see now you
take that progress and then you in turn
put it in the hands of an indestructible
man and what that represents is progress
that can't be stopped progress that
cannot be prevented and that's the fear
that croods and people like him had at
that point in time he said what if
brashear had turned against us suppose
he was more like gabriel prosser or
malcolm x now if those guys don't know
who gabriel prosser was he was a
blacksmith during the age of slavery who
planned to slave rebellion malcolm x we
know who malcolm x is right his name
speaks for itself and he says nuclear
missiles were not going to stop this guy
so we had to do something and then he
said there was another issue that was
going on now what it does is it switches
to the pentagon war room in 1962 where
they're having a conversation with
bolivar trask now this is one of the
best things that i loved about this
story is the way that kevin grevious
rolled all this in when they're having
this conversation with trask the initial
concern here is that perhaps adam
brashear is a mutant and in doing so it
represents a clear and present danger
and that while while you know bolivar
trust says i'm not saying that mr
president but i do know that the
presence of superhumans like the blue
marvel proves that there is a
microevolutionary change taking place
within the human genome that allows for
such being to exist and he says simply
that the problems we face with the blue
marble are only the beginning and appear
in the coming or at least will expand in
the coming years the superheroes will
present a credible threat not just for
our world in our country but for all
over this world itself from different
races and socioeconomic strata as well
and that's when with all this
information that's being given right
that like this whole representative idea
of blue marvel people gaining powers and
becoming essentially unstoppable that it
could destabilize the entire planet
could change the face of the cold war or
create a new kind of war altogether
communism could be the least of their
concerns and when they ask what do we do
trask he says in my opinion admiral we
must remain vigilant we have to be wide
awake we have to control the coming
storm the response is starkin here
saying so that's how project wide awake
began a whisper in the dark by men
afraid of what they don't understand
that's the origin of it all now the
funny thing about this is for those of
you guys who aren't familiar with
project wide awake it's one of the
coolest concepts ever in the history of
marvel comics so with project wide awake
the way this played out is that in the
old school chris claremont days it was
really a bolivar trash concept but it
was also just this massive and huge
multi-intelligence
organizational apparatus right the
nature behind project wide awake at its
core was to contain and control the
mutant threat but you also got things
like the commission on superhuman
activities so project wide awake
extended beyond simply just mutants and
then expanded to the idea of superheroes
the commission on superhuman activities
for example was the organization that
fired steve rogers as captain america
arguing that the captain america name
was owned by the government and replaced
steve rogers with john walker u.s agent
who basically turned out to be a [ __ ]
show so they brought steve rogers back
because literally john walker was
killing people but the whole thing
behind this is that the the project wide
awake initiative that entire program
started it like the president of the
united states it stretched down to state
legislatures right so members of the
house and the senate intelligence
organizations the cia the fbi state and
local sheriff's office local like local
police force the whole nine yards it was
just this gigantic task that had been
undertaken by the federal government to
contain and control the mutant threat so
that's where you got guys like henry
peter geirk bolivar trask developing the
initial or the original sentinel program
when he was essentially taken out of the
picture project wide awake at the hands
of the federal government moved this
sentinel program into the hands of
stephen lang not related to scotland by
the way but that's what led to the
sentinels as you most commonly know them
especially if you ever watched x-men the
animated series but it was a great big
huge venture what kevin grievous came in
and did in this story which i loved is
he said it all started with the blue
marvel that the blue marvel popped up as
a black superhero in the 1960s scared
the hell out of the government and in
response as an act of desperation the
government turned of all of our trask
and that's where project wide awake came
from so it was a really really cool idea
because in return or at least in this
whole thing you have this this idea
where starks just like
like the entirety of project wide awake
was a policy of fear and repression and
the response of cruz is like well it
happens and that pisses off stark to no
end right because he's like you put this
guy in a box and you threw the key away
just so you could sleep at night and for
no other reason than the fact that it
was a skin color because the reality
here is that if this was like a white
guy who popped up nobody would have been
scared they wouldn't have hit the panic
button the way that they did and if
anything the desire would have been to
reel that guy in there's a couple ways
that we know that we know that because
of the fact that steve rogers captain
america was the original weapon one but
if you go back and you read uh grant
morrison's new x-men one of the first
things he establishes is that the desire
to create super soldiers that was
captain america to contain and control
the mutant threat at the very early
outset of project wide awake right
before project wide awake actually
became project wide awake then when you
had this realization that people have
been popping up historically with mutant
powers that the early stages right you
could kind of call it the precursor to
white awake came in the form of weapons
plus captain america was weapon one
world war ii was a field test and the
whole intention was to see how he would
play out in a combat scenario and if he
performed admirably he'd be brought back
to the united states his mind would be
wiped and he would be turned into an
anti-mutant or at least the first in a
series of anti-mutant police force type
guys right super soldiers that would
allow them to contain and control that
threat as we know captain america was
frozen in ice so without his location
being known by the various by really
anybody out there in the world weapons
plus turned to weapons two and three and
four and five and six running all the
way up to weapon x wolf reign and then
the ones that came after that step for
kakuz deadpool phantom x all that kind
of stuff so it's one of these things
where like if someone like captain
america or somebody like uh nuke for
example frank simpson those were
acceptable and they were used by the
federal government to achieve a goal
whereas when it came to adam berscher it
was lock this guy up and throw away the
key we got to kick him out because this
guy's dangerous right so kevin grievous
draws this clear parallel between the
fact of or really between the the skin
color of adam bashir and the response of
the federal government and so in the end
the statement that that crude says here
is that all you hypocritical liberals
are all alike you want the world to read
like a mother's day card but you don't
want to do what's necessary to keep it
safe a safe world costs something
somebody somewhere out there has to pay
the piper when the bill comes due and so
at the end of the day what he says is
like in order to close the book on adam
brashear right because it wasn't enough
for the president to just give him the
presidential medal of freedom and cinema
on his way that there had to be some
kind of a response there had to be
something that went on and so far is
removing this guy from the equation so
what the president did is he sent him on
a final mission that there was basically
an alien scout that they had determined
here now this alien is not overly
important for this conversation it will
be later on but not right now but there
was an alien scout that had shown up and
adam beshear was sent into space despite
the fact that he had been asked to step
down by the president as a final mission
which adam beshear accepted because
remember the stance of adam is that he
is a protector of the world not really a
protector of any one particular race and
that in this fight between the two that
what had happened is they were hoping
that these guys would kill each other
that what it would do is it would lead
to adam beshear dying at the hands of
this alien and vice versa and just kind
of rid them of this entire situation
that didn't happen instead what ended up
taking place is the energy signature of
adam bershear started just hitting this
kind of fever pitch and then they never
saw him again and that was it right and
so the response of stark is okay so like
the avengers were almost killed by
anti-man out there and the the only one
that we know of that could have defeated
this guy your bigotry got him killed
right and so in the end of the day cruz
is like you haven't been listening right
not 20 people knew about that alien
encounter but we were able to use part
of it to bury the truth and add a layer
to the cover story it made the blue
marvel's disappearance of the world more
credible if anyone ever dug too deep and
so when stark asked what are you talking
about the response to this guy was we
had an alternative right the protocol
files were incomplete and he gives the
protocol files directly to tony stark
and so what this does is it switches
over to silver spring maryland where you
have a woman of course who's basically
there but like of course there's a knock
at the door there's tony stark and when
they ask her or at least when they start
talking to her we find out this woman's
name is mrs brashear right this is the
wife of adam and in one of the most
interesting if not crazy moments in this
story they asked her do you know where
your husband is right is he in and she's
like no he's a class like you're tony
stark right he's like yeah you know and
she's like what's what's all of this you
know to deal with he's like well it's
just a matter a matter of national
security ma'am you know and she was like
this is ridiculous she can't let me just
barge into our home and start doing this
and he says miss frazier i don't have
time for that and when her response is
why did you call me that he's like
marlene frazier agent314 that's your
real name right your code name is
agent314 that's correct right and she
tries to play it off like she doesn't
know what she's talking about he's like
the world needs blue marble this
exchange here on the surface is tony
stark kind of being like i mean look we
know what's going on right like you know
but the reality is what he's doing is
effectively blackmailing her he's
tugging at those strings he's like we
know you started out as an agent of
shield we know you're not actually the
wife of adam berscher i mean you are but
but things aren't necessarily what they
seem so either you can help us out here
or we can link it to your husband about
what's going on right it's really strong
arm in here and so as a response of
course she ends up calling up adam
bashir and then basically letting him
know hey like the federal government's
looking for you again right like they're
trying to find you so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace